make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and i just woke up right and we got
to run through this because
i have a dentist appointment at 11
o'clock and it's currently 8 30. right
so we gotta like
we gotta we gotta run our hind parts
through this but uh you guys get the
enjoyment of hearing my voice
first thing in the morning yes you do
okay so so we're picking up with venom
beyond
and this is part three now in the second
part we kind of had this we were sort of
introduced to this guy named virus which
by the way my voice will change as we go
over the course this video you'll notice
it by the time we get to the end
and in the second really in the the
first two parts we were introduced to a
character named virus who didn't really
know anything about all we knew was that
somewhere along the line something eddie
brock had done it basically ruined his
life and the guy just kind of had a
vendetta for him and was chasing after
him right so it's almost kind of like a
reversal of the modern or at least of
the old school spider-man venom kind of
story right where venom just popped up
one day and was like you ruined my life
you know and then him and spider-man
fought the other thing that happened
here is that as they were trying to make
their escape they of course were dealing
with the maker you know the the ultimate
universe reed richards and all that kind
of stuff kind of the holdover from uh
hickman's avengers and new avengers and
secret wars and where maker ended up
returning back to his own universe in
the ultimate universe when brock and his
son
ended up passing through the portal
ended up going to the portal they ended
up in this alternate reality and one of
the first things we learned right off
the bat is that the people in this
alternate reality are largely all
symbiotes right like symbiotes you know
seem to have conquered the world and so
we didn't really know a whole lot
about what was going on all we knew is
that there was someone just a guy named
codex
right and so what this does is it gives
us a little more context here and
basically saying that this guy codex
is the uncontested ruler of the world
right every city every state
every corner of this planet lies in the
palm of his hand right and day by day
his grip constantly grows tighter now
the reason why this matters is because
what it shows is that while he is the
quote-unquote uncontested ruler of the
world what it also means is that
not everybody out there is a is a
symbiote right not everybody out there
has been turned and so we basically end
up picking up with him and otto octavius
of course otto octavius being one of the
people who have been turned and then
kind of asking the question this virus
guy have we managed to get the symbiote
to bond to him and notice how kind of
disregarding this is right when otto
octavia says yeah but the symbiote
basically chooses its host
right and this this simi is not choosing
this guy right it's just kind of
studying him it's examining him for some
reason and the response of codex is then
kill the symbiote if it doesn't bond and
try a new one but in this day and age a
lot of work has been done to almost kind
of humanize the venom symbiotes and so
you can almost imagine that seemingly
kind of like being scared of being
killed
right like that kind of a thing but the
other part of this is that uh
kodak starts going over all this
equipment that virus had right and he
says like i need to know about all this
stuff
tell me about what this stuff is right
virus like this this suit of yours right
they kind of tell like you know wake
them up virus is kind of you know
panicking saying hey like let me out of
here i'll do whatever you want but when
kodak starts going through and looking
at this stuff he's like this is
hodgepodge
you've got like ancient goblet goblin
technology here right so just super old
school stuff you've got war machine
components that have been decommissioned
for years this is all just junkyard
stuff
right and the response of this guy virus
is it's all i could afford right like i
bought it off the tinkerer and some
black markets and that's where you get a
little more of an explanation here right
the codex basically says tinker's been
dead for a long time
so is tony stark and so so is norman
osborne right i killed them all like
they've all been dead for a long long
time
presumably they refused to bond or when
this initial war kind of broke out you
know we can kind of
we can assume it's that we can call it
that that they were some of the first to
fall right but whatever the case is
they're basically dead but when virus
says that he was hunting he was chasing
after eddie brock and his son
that's when codex begins to freak out
and it's like tell me everything that's
going on now from here
we switch back over to eddie and himself
or eddie himself along with his son
and then with the agent venom core and
what you have here is his initial
encounter with ann weighing now remember
ann wayne was
kind of the wife at one point or really
was the wife of of eddie brock at one
point and then she basically ended up
killing herself in in marvel comics
right at some point later down the road
but
the biggest moment about her is that she
was she venom and so where she's been
gone for a long time
the fact that eddie sees her is
astonishing to him right like i thought
you've been i thought you were dead i
thought you were gone the response of
of anne is like i thought you were dead
you've got to be working for him like
eddie brock doesn't isn't here anymore
so like what's going on right like like
tell me your story and that's when he
basically he kind of tells what i
already told you guys right that he
would he ended up falling into a
wormhole you know when he was chasing
after the maker and
so on and so forth and and you know he
says like he knows it sounds crazy but
she's like prove it how did you get that
symbiote and he basically tells a story
and he says like
in the world that i'm from i went to a
church when i was in a really bad way i
was gonna i was gonna off myself
and then this symbiote seemingly came
down from nowhere and then bonded to me
and my initial response was to get back
to peter parker because peter parker was
the one that led to me
being in that place discredited me and
then the venom symbiote felt cast off
and abandoned by peter so we kind of had
this mutual hatred
of spider-man and in that we became
venom and then we tried to kill
spider-man
and then over the years i've kind of
seen the error of my ways right like
over the years i've seen the air of my
ways and now i'm kind of being a good
guy
and that's when when he's kind of like i
don't really understand she's like this
is all because of you
and he's like he's kind of what are you
talking about and she's like in on my
world in this world when you went into
that church
you pulled the trigger and it's just
kind of like wow like it's it's
it's like it was the craziest thing
because like she's like she's like yeah
like you killed yourself like you
actually went
went through with it now of course this
seems to indicate the idea that she was
pregnant with dylan at the time
and so what we end up finding out is
that in the the aftermath of eddie
basically dying here right that that
anne was pissed right she was angry that
he that he just took himself away from
her right that he basically left her in
that way they
of course again were like still married
they were still a couple you know that
kind of a thing
and so in her grief she actually ended
up going to that church where eddie did
himself in
and the symbiote was still there right
the semi was still there and just
waiting on somebody to arrive
and that's what happened now we're not
necessarily given the kind of gaps
in between right between the time that
happened and what's going on here but
what we are told
is that the reason why her symbiote
doesn't look like the others right the
reason why those guys symbiotes look
different
is because of the fact that her cement
immediately started spawning right in
the expectation the preparation this
something was basically coming and
that's what's kind of weird here is
because
donnie cates did a lot insofar as as
kind of adjusting the venom history like
the history of the symbiote and all that
kind of stuff in marvel comics but even
if we say that the death of eddie brock
took place
in this alternate reality around the
same time that it happened in the main
marvel universe then there wouldn't
really be a need for the semi to start
spawning
right off the bat right because null was
not really considered to be an enemy
that would be returning anytime soon but
if we're
assuming the timelines basically
happened at around the same time meaning
that null's arrival in the sense that he
was basically kind of broken out of his
multiversal tomb in the main marvel
universe if that happened
around the same time across all
universes and so you know it's basically
in this moment that it took place then
it would make sense that our symbiote
started spawning and that seems to have
been what happened here but again it's a
little murky when you're talking about
things happening around the same time in
alternate realities but
what she says is that along that
timeline somewhere that rex strickland
was one of the first people really the
first person to be bonded to a symbiote
and that that
rex strickland and the guy president
thomas who was kind of the co-creator i
guess really the the main mind behind
the shadow unit when they died in the
war against codex that what it did is it
left behind some symbiotes for you know
for
other people to be bonded to right
basically for her to create her own kind
of agent venom group and that they
basically use these old tunnels right
these old tunnels that shield used to
use to transport cargo around you know
that kind of thing and and so
what we basically end up getting is the
revelation of who these guys are the
first one we get
is peter parker right peter parker is
part of asian the agent venom
core right so peter parker's venom in
this alternate reality the next one is
cletus cassidy which is crazy the third
one
is is like agent wade wilson right so
like
deadpool is basically agent venom in
this alternate reality which is kind of
nuts and then andy benton whatever so
the craziest thing about this
is that eddie brock gets pissed off
about like cletus cassidy being on here
now the funny thing about this
is that the the response of and weighing
is
cletus was the first one to join us yes
he's had a past but with rex's training
and a lot of help from our our science
officer
he's one of the best agents we have the
reason why that's cool is because what
it shows is cletus cassidy was carnage
somewhere along the line which really
kind of fleshes out the history of anne
wayne
that her history as venom in this
alternate reality was very similar to
that of eddie brock that somewhere along
the line she most likely ended up
fighting peter parker that in that
conflict the venom spin a venom symbiote
kind of spit out a symbiote of its own
which came in the form of carnage which
binded itself to cletus cassidy
it most likely took ann weighing his
venom and peter parker to team up to
beat cletus cassidy and then he's
basically kind of been reformed and now
he's a good guy again that's kind of
what seems to be going on here but the
crazy thing about this
is that the spider sense of peter parker
starts going haywire and it's like
something's coming like we have to move
right we have to get out of here as fast
as we can
and that's when we basically end up
getting this kind of crazy
symbiote hit squad right the juggernaut
the thing ben grimm
you've got omega red you've got saber
tooth and you've got wolverine this
is a nuts team like just to throw it out
there this is a pretty hard hitting team
what's also kind of crazy about this i'm
not even really impressed that like
wolverine or
like ben graham or any of those guys i'm
impressed that juggernaut right the like
somehow codex managed to get a symbiote
on to juggernaut agent venom basically
goes into
the agent venom squad basically attacks
these guys and this is actually a cool
battle to see because for the most part
they're able to get the upper hand to a
degree and that's one of the big
differences here is that
it looks as though being bonded to a
semi especially with
the character of juggernaut being bonded
with a symbiote kind of means
you know like one way or the other right
like for example venom is able to
overpower juggernaut now
in no universe would anybody ever
believe that venom could overpower the
juggernaut right i mean you're talking
about a sheer force of nature right when
the juggernaut starts moving his
movement can't really be stopped
especially when you're talking about
like like world breaker hulk for example
had to divert his movement he couldn't
punch juggernaut out of the way but like
venom being able to like
knock juggernaut off of his feet i don't
really believe that and so it looks like
maybe it's kane marco in illusion only
right in symbiote form
only or maybe it's kane marco with like
his look but he you know he's got that
same size so maybe the simulate just
makes him look big but he doesn't really
have the crimson gem of sidorak right
it's just the way the symbiote makes him
look i don't really know but i
have a hard time reconciling venom
getting the upper hand
on on eddie brock it's the same thing
with like with other stuff right like
ben grimm
being able to to be you know to be
knocked down and hit pretty hard at
least enough to
almost subdue him by a venom's to me
right doesn't really work that way but
again
like every time shots are taken by these
guys right bullets are shot and so on
and so forth the guys themselves almost
kind of seem to break down and then kind
of reconstitute themselves and so you
actually end up getting
venom and carnage teaming up to fight
juggernaut which
looks amazing if i'm being honest with
you guys like it looks absolutely
amazing now the biggest question you
have to ask here is
dylan dylan the son of eddie brock has
the ability to dominate the wills of
symbiotes why doesn't he
do that here we don't really know
instead look at this amazing moment
where wade wilson basically pops up and
says all right guys time for plan x the
plan the x
the x stands for explode and so it's
like everybody run they're like what are
you doing he's like i don't know man but
i'm the only guy who's gonna survive
this and then just like
literally detonates himself right and
seems to to bring like a whole bunch of
these guys down now from there you
switch back over to uh to auto octavius
and a codex
and like finally the the venom symbiote
has bonded itself to this guy and it's
like we've achieved full symbiosis in
the sense that
instead of years past instead of
previous instances where we saw the
venom symbiote bonding to a host which
basically meant
enveloping that host instead what you
have here is the venom symbiote bonding
with the host on a genetic level
this person seems to be irrevocably
bonded to the venom symbiote now it may
be that you can undo that but it doesn't
really seem to be the case instead once
this guy pops up you know the response
of codex is your name is virus yes well
we need to change that
and one of the things he says is like
eddie paralyzed me right he took my legs
he's not taking my name from now on
you can call me scorpion and that's when
virus refers to him as mr gargan this
guy was was matt gargan now here's the
thing
one he looks ridiculously awesome as
scorpion and he almost kind of looks
like the
the vindicator from spawn right like as
the scorpion which
really looks cool right i mean i got it
just it looks amazing right
that's just the best thing i can say he
just looks absolutely amazing and then
number two
i love this idea because here's the
thing i never really cared about matt
gargan until he became venom right like
until he took over the venom symbiote
during like during the events leading up
to dark rain and during dark rain i
loved that but basically says like swear
allegiance to me
swear allegiance to me and serve me as
one of my henchmen here on this world
and bring me eddie brock
and so from there you end up switching
over to you know back to the team
more or less to uh you know with and
weighing and all them and they basically
get back to their their base of
operations and we end up finding out
that their science guy right like their
main science guy is reed richards you
know and he's kind of like okay so like
one i got to deal with another reed
richards but two this guy looks like
he's insane
and anne's like yeah i mean he is kind
of off his rocker
but here's the thing if it wasn't for
him we never would have made it this far
and so eddie introduces himself and then
his son introduces himself he's like
what's your name he's like my name's
dylan
sir like dylan brock and it's like dylan
and then it's like like people just like
what in the heck
and then like anne wayne is just like uh
tell me is he
your son and he's like yeah i mean
that's that's like he's my like what's
the big deal and the response of anne is
like dude it's him
on our world eddie dylan is codex dylan
is the one who conquered the world
using all the venom symbiotes but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain i told you my voice
would change make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you